here's Anna Navarro
Anna Navarro who once was a republican
she was a conservative I think she was
Marco Rubio's campaign manager years ago
if I'm not mistaken right it was
campaign manager or publicist yeah here
she is just lying about Trump and
DeSantis and everything happening in
Florida and freedom and all of the stuff
go it's not you know it's not just Trump
the when he's saying I'm your Warrior I
think he's saying I'm your Warrior not
fighting everybody he's fighting I'll
tell you who he's fighting let me answer
you he's fighting transgenders drag
queen he's fighting drag queens he's
fired you know they're fighting black
history they're fighting proof they're
fighting facts they're fighting science
that's what they're fighting
but I think that doesn't matter Sonny
it's about it's about manufactured
culture wars it's not about logic it's
let's make things up that enrage people
that aggrieve people that piss people
off that make them feel oppressed that
make them feel like big fear of a loss
I'm going to make them feel that I'm
going to fight for them and Rhonda Sands
is saying the same thing and there was
something you know the the entire
Republican party because it's happening
in so many states is is taking this
manufactured cultural War wait
manufactured culture War that's a good
one
I wish I'd come up with that one because
that's pretty much what she's doing but
let's just go into so you guys get it
right you know she's she's just lying
and she's again the culture war is
coming to us none of us were screaming
about drag queens or transgender
anything we were all over the race stuff
nobody thought any being racist was cool
or any of this stuff you guys have done
this so again it's just you just need
the mirror right like if you looked at
yourself in the mirror you might see who
the real racist is but real quick just
to go through some of the things she
said so so Trump and DeSantis and the
Republicans they're the ones going after
transgender people first off I don't
know anyone that is saying that an adult
transgender person doesn't have the
right to live however they wish once you
are 18 if you wish to put on a tutu as a
300 pound man and become a ballerina God
bless you we're not going to show an
image of it that's one thing then
they're going after drag queens well
they're not going after drag queens who
are performing for adults in nightclubs
as has been happening in America for
probably a hundred years they're going
after drag queens which is a hyper
sexual performance in front of children
and generally speaking that is thought
of as wrong right but these are the same
people who want third graders to have
books about getting hand jobs and how to
give hand jobs and then if you ban that
book they tell you that you're racist or
something like that then she of course
said they're going after blacks of
course they're not going after blacks we
already did this nonsense related to the
AP course they're going after history no
it's you guys with the made up history
1619 project Etc they're going after
truth well that's a real doozy
considering we just finished three years
of coveted you people lied about
mandates and you'll about lied about
social distancing and masks and vaxes
and everything else they're going after
facts yeah we'll ask these people what
gender is someone who has a penis and
then tell me who's screwing up the facts
around here and then science I mean same
one on that so it's every single thing
thank you
[Music]